اعلنت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مدينه
الخليل منطقه عسكريه مغلقه بعد مقتل
مستوطنه اسرائيليه واصابه مستوطن في اطلاق
نار لم يعرف منفذه كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا
ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما ابرز
التغيرات في نهج واساليب وادوات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بالضفه الغربيه وكيف نقرا فشل
سياسه القبضه الامنيه التي تتبناها حكوم
اليمين المتطرف في اسرائيل وما موقف
واشنطن مما يجري في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
جراء سياسه
الاحتلال الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
وفلسطين عموما في حاله انتفاضه حقيقيه
تجري على شكل موجات منذ عام 2015 واقتنع
الشعب الفلسطيني بانه ما حك جلدك مثل ظفرك
ولن ياتي احد لمساعدتنا نقاط المخربين
الشعب الفلسطيني يقاوم وسواء كان في دوله
تدعم الفلسطينيين هنا او هناك او لم تكن
هذا الشعب سيقاوم هذا الظلم وسيقام هذا
الاضطهاد الشعب الفلسطيني ادرك قضيه بسيطه
وواضحه ان اسرائيل لا تفهم الى لغه
القوه اسرائيليون يواجهون وضعا يفشلون فيه
ليل نهار في قمع هذه المقاومه او في كسرها
عنصر عامل مركزي الذي يريد
ان يستمر التطور ضد مواطنين اسرائيليين
اسرائيليون دائما يبحثوا عن دوله ليحملها
المسؤوليه كان زمان يقول ان المشكله
الاتحاد السوفيتي ثم كانت المشكله مصر في
زمن عبد الناصر ثم اصبحت المشكله سوريا ثم
العراق والان ايران وغدا ربما سيتحدث عن
اذربيجان كل هذه اعتقالات هي اعتقالات ضد
مخ ين هذام بيوت هذام بيوت مخربين جوهر
المشكله الاحتلال الاجرامي القامع للشعب
الفلسطيني
229 شهيد منذ بدايه هذا العام منهم 38 طفل
قتلهم جيش الاحتلال بناء بيوت
احياء عمارات في ارض اجدادنا هذا لا يخالف
مع القانون الدولي القانون الدولي
يتحدث
اجرام اسرائيلي نسف اي فرصه لاي عمليه
عمليه سلام في المنطقه ورساله ارسلها
الاسرائيليون سمعتوها قبل قليل يقول لك
هذه اراضي اسرائيل كل فلسطين دوله اسرائيل
هي اراضي حتى غزه بعتبرها اراضي يهوديه
نحن نتعرض لاحتلال واستيطان استعماري
اجرامي مخالف لكل القوانين الدوليه ومس
بكرامتنا واذلال على 650 حاجز اجرامي
اسرائيلي وفوق كل ذلك يقطع عنا المياه
ويمارسوا اسوا نظام تمييز عنصري في تاريخ
البشريه
الحديث اعتقد ان
واشنطن تراقب بعين ملئها القلق لان هذا
الامر قد يستمر بالتصعيد
وهذا سيتطلب المزيد من التدخل الفعال من
جانب اداره بايدن الولايات المتحده
واداراتها المتعاقبه تتحمل مسؤوليه كبيره
جدا فيما يجري لانها امتنعت عن فرض اي
اجراء عقابي ضد اسرائيل الولايات المتحده
كانت مقصره في تعاملها مع الاوضاع في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه وكان هناك الكثير من
فك
الارتباط
والتخلي
واتباع
مقاربه حذره اكثر من اللزوم في واقع كان
يزداد تفاقما وسوءا وانا لا اقبل من السيد
وين سلند ممثل الامم المتحده ان يساوي بين
الطرفين هذا نفاق سياسي مرفوض لا يمكن
المساوى بين الذي يمارس الاحتلال ومن هم
تحت الاحتلال تاكيد لدى
الديمقراطيين واداره بايدن اللي هنا ان
هناك اصوات تطالب بممارسه مواقف اكثر
تشددا بينما في الجانب الجمهوري في
الكونجرس هناك دعم قوي الكل يدعم
نتنياهو وسياساته وتكتيكاته العدوانيه انا
غير مؤمن بالدوله الفلسطينيه مستقله دوله
فلسطينيه مستقله تكون مركز ارهابي الذي
التي هذه الدوله تهدد على الشعوب العربيه
وتكون مدعومه من قبل ايران كلامك يخالف
تماما كل القوانين الدوليه وقرارات
الشرعيه الدوليه لماذا تقولين ذلك ربما
المقاومه الفلسطينيه تشكرك لانه هذا
الخطاب ربما هو الذي اع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه الى الى
مجدها